today on the matt welsh show as the left
continues to use 1984 as more of an
instruction manual than a warning trans
activists have successfully bullied
webster's dictionary into changing the
definition of female
though the new definition makes no sense
at all and that's not the most orwellian
thing happening this week gender
activists are also pushing
anthropologists to impose gender theory
onto the corpses of our ancestors we'll
talk about all that plus congressional
democrats make the case for packing the
court the la times gets in trouble for
acknowledging that solar power isn't all
it's cracked up to be and our daily
cancellation mass hysteria and outrage
as a sesame street character is accused
of committing a hate crime against a
black child all of that and more today
on the matt wall show
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't know how easy it is to uh adjust
your spending and saving strategies all
you got to do is call my friends at
american financing that's america's home
for home loans there you can get a free
no obligation financial review so you
can understand new ways to get out of
debt faster i mean it's really very
simple there's no pressure there's no
upfront or hidden fees just a simple
conversation around ways to add hundreds
back to your monthly budget maybe that's
by consolidating debt maybe it's by
adjusting your mortgage terms or even
accessing cash believe me these guys can
help in whatever way you need and you
don't need perfect credit to make it
happen they want to help as many
families as possible it's one of the
many reasons why i like them so much and
also again it's the simplicity which is
so great
for a stupid person like myself so why
not take 10 minutes and learn more if
you start soon you can close as fast as
10 days just call 866 866-569-4711
that's
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls 182 334 nmls consumeraccess.org
you know arguing with the left is like
trying to win a wrestling match against
a very large slug the difficulty is is
not that your opponent is strong and
vigorous but that he's slippery and
slimy and difficult to get a grip on his
gelatinous amorphous nature may make him
hideous and a horror to behold but it
does bless him with certain advantages
and and when this greasy gooey beast
also has his complete has complete
institutional dominance
the challenges in opposition to them are
even greater uh it's not easy to live in
a culture where every institution is
controlled by a giant slug is what i'm
trying to say but that's our situation
like it or not and so we must remain on
our toes ready to adjust
for example uh in arguments over the
issue of gender i have often like many
of us had recourse back to the
dictionary you know the slug insists on
using words apart from their actual
dictionary meaning and so we on the
other side will point to the dictionary
and say no that's not what the word
means here's what the dictionary says
it's a good reference it's what it's
supposed to be a reference for what
words mean
and it's a fine tactic
until the day comes as it has today
apparently
when the slug uses its mucusy power to
change the dictionary itself so it came
to my attention this morning i don't
know exactly when this happened but it
certainly happened recently
that miriam webster probably the most
famous and widely cited dictionary in
the world has at the behest of trans
activists
change the definition of the word female
now it's kind of a clever trick because
um the dictionary has not as most people
expected would happen
change the definition of woman see i
thought that's what they would do now
that i have all with all this what is a
woman's stuff eventually the pressure
would be on the dictionary to just
change the definition to say something
like a woman is anyone who identifies as
a woman and then uh all these people
that were you know thrown for a loop by
my film then they could just point the
dictionary and say see it says it right
there it's a dictionary definition
but they haven't changed that definition
see according to webster
woman still means adult human female
okay good
but what does female mean well with its
latest addition made under pressure from
the slug
webster defines female the following way
here's what it says a of relating to or
being the sex that typically has the
capacity to bear young or produce eggs
that's the first definition that's the
transphobic one we're all used to
but then b
having a gender identity
that is the opposite of male
now
one might point out a number of logical
problems here the first being that
definition b
made at the command of trans activist
actually contradicts what those
activists have always said
they insist that sex and gender identity
are two completely different things yet
here webster conflates the two
also webster while trying to appease the
left still reaffirmed the binary because
really they have no choice
their r says the dictionary now
males
and those who are the opposite of male
which means that sex is still binary and
not only that but if you're a female now
um you're also defining yourself
by males like you you're the definition
of who you are depends on
males because you're just the opposite
of that
sex is still binary
just in slightly different words yet if
the implication of gender identity as
it's used here
means that webster is claiming uh that
men can be female which is what gender
identity means it means that you know
you're just whatever you feel like you
are
then the first definition definition a
doesn't hold
so they will have given
two definitions of a word which cancel
each other out
leaving us with no definition at all
what you really end up with is you know
what is a female a a person with a
capacity to produce offspring b
not a person with the capacity to
produce offspring so what is a female
who knows nothing
they might as well simply erase the
definition and the word entirely because
that's the effect here
everything must be rewritten for the
almighty slug
and what cannot be coherently rewritten
must be just erased
and this includes history of course
that's that's really the first thing
that has to go
and that brings us to the other
orwellian update that we have for you
today um we can no longer simply point
to the dictionary because the
dictionaries have been compromised even
dictionaries are now political vessels
nothing can be left alone in this
culture the slug cannot allow anything
to simply exist and perform the function
that it's supposed to perform everything
must exist to serve the slug first and
foremost
and so another argument that i've often
used must now be uh recalibrated a
little bit
i have observed as many others have many
times that that despite anyone's gender
identity quote-unquote the fact is that
when they die and i said this on dr phil
i said what is a woman uh you know when
you die and are buried in the ground
and your flesh rots away leaving only
your bones
all that will be left
almost all is your sex no matter how you
identified when archaeologists and
anthropologists of the future exhume
your grave and look at your remains they
will declare you male or female
your self-identity will be gone but your
sex will remain
this is how deeply embedded it is it is
the last thing about you
that anyone will be able to know
just as it's one of the first things
about you that anyone will be able to
know
well all of that remains true i mean
none of that has ever changed has
changed or ever will
the only adjustment that uh we have to
make now
is in the assumption
that archaeologists and anthropologists
of the future will actually be free and
willing to make these kinds of
statements about people of the past
a report in the college fix suggests
otherwise
it says quote as soon as ancient human
remains are excavated archaeologists
begin the work of determining a number
of traits about the individual including
age race and gender
but a new school of thought within
archaeology is pushing scientists to
think twice about assigning gender to
ancient human remains
it is possible to determine whether a
skeleton is from a biological male or
female using objective observations
based on the size and shape of the bones
criminal forensic detectives for example
do it frequently in their line of work
but gender activists argue scientists
cannot know how an ancient individual
identified themselves
quote
uh you might know the argument that the
archaeologists who find your bones one
day will assign you the same gender as
you had at birth so regardless of
whether you transition you can't escape
your assigned sex tweeted canadian
master's degree candidate emma palladino
last week paladino who's seeking an
advanced degree in archaeology called
assigning gender to an ancient human
bull
quote labeling remains male or female is
rarely the end goal of any excavation
anyway wrote palladino the
bioarchaeology of the individual is what
we aim for factoring in absolutely
everything we discover about a person
into a nuanced and open-ended biography
of their life
now it's not just one whack job saying
this it's many whack jobs there's a
whole movement in the field now to
conform the work of anthropology
with the demands of trans activists the
fix continues
quote gender activists have formed a
group called the trans-doe task force to
explore ways in which current standards
and forensic human identification do a
disservice to people who do not clearly
fit the gender binary we propose a
gender expansive approach to human
identification by combing missing and
unidentified databases looking for
contextual clues such as um descendants
wearing uh clothing culturally coded to
a
decedent's rather wearing clothing
culturally coded to a gender other than
their assigned sex the group's mission
statement reads
we maintain our own database of missing
and unidentified people who we've
determined may be transgender or gender
variant as most current databases
systems do not permit comparison of
missing to unidentified across different
binary sex categories the group rights
uh which which by the way means that uh
we're talking about the forensic element
of this uh forensic detectives people
working cold cases and everything if
they really apply this it makes their
work impossible it's you can't do it
anymore
because usually you
uh find the remains of someone and then
you try to match them with a database
figure out who it is
you know who are these remains and then
you can figure out how they died
well in order to match them you first
one of the things you have to know is
okay well the age race and sex and then
you take that and then you go to the
database of missing people you say okay
well this matches that person
but if they're looking at the remains
and saying well we don't know their sex
we have no idea we can't possibly know
this is just a person
then there's no way to narrow it down
and ever match that person with a
missing person which means that the
whole field of cold cases forensic work
all of that is just out the window
including the entire field of
anthropology and archaeology all of it
is done out the window along with the
dictionary and reality itself a little
more here from the fix it says this
february
university of kansas associate professor
jennifer raff published origen a genetic
history of the americas in which she
argued that there are no neat divisions
between physically or genetically male
or female individuals
raph suggests it suggested scientists
cannot know the gender of a 9 000 year
old biologically peruvian hunter because
they don't know whether the hunter
identified as male or female a duality
concept she says was quote imposed by
christian colonizers
well she's right in a way
nobody can know the gender of a 9 000
year old peruvian hunter because nobody
9 000 years ago or 900 years ago or 90
years ago had a gender the concept
hadn't been invented yet and imposed on
the world by woke leftist pervert
colonizers that's the only kind of
colonizing that really happens anymore
in the west anyway
everyone back in those days had only a
sex and that was it they may have had
different words in different languages
to communicate it obviously but there
were people who got pregnant
and people who did the impregnating and
those were the two categories
the only two firm categories any society
has ever had until ours
these activists disguise the scientists
recognize this reality and they see the
problem it creates for them because
this is one of the things one of the
questions they found it so difficult to
answer i mean they find every question
difficult to answer but especially this
one which is why should anyone
listen to your rambling nonsense
that you just came up with a few years
ago like why should we care
you came up with this stuff a few years
ago why should i care about that why
should anyone care about it
why should we allow you
to redefine concepts
that have endured for millennia
for millennia billions of people have
lived lived and died and had no problem
with these categories have not caused
any problems for them it's been it has
not caused any confusion and then you
come along and you you want to change
all of this
and not only change it for yourselves
but but insist that everyone else has to
look at it differently
well they can't explain why we should do
that so
they seek to rewrite history and
superimpose their ideological fixations
onto the past
even the very ancient past
i mean the level of narcissism on
display
here is monumental psychotic
unfathomable
they now wish to perform a sort of
posthumous baptism on the entire human
race christening everyone
all of our ancestors in the waters of
gender theory
rewriting the history and lives and
legacies of all of our ancestors in
order to justify their modern day sexual
fixations and fetishes
i mean it was bad enough when they
condemned all of our ancestors as bigots
and racists and transphobes refusing to
give them the grace of historical
context that was bad enough
what they seek to do now is so much
worse
rather than condemn
the ghosts of our
great-great-grandparents
they'll instead recruit them
enlist them
to the lgbt cause against their will
a sort of posthumous conscription
a selective service of the dead if you
will
they seek not only to build their own
reality in their own universe but to
extend their reach across space
as well as time into the past
and then on to the present and out
towards the future
and they can do all of this
or at least attempt it
but the truth remains no matter what
and it falls to us to defend it against
all threats
even giant fat slimy slugs
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and it matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you
you know the thing is when you go to a
regular mattress store and you buy some
some just factory made
mattress you're really buying a mattress
made for someone else not made for you
specifically why do that when you can
use helix with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep everybody is
unique and helix knows that
knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down mattress is great for uh spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains and even a plus mattress listen if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress that
you're matched to and the mattress comes
right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again they have a
10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but i guarantee you will i know
i do um i love my own helix mattress not
yours i'm trying to say helix even has
financing options and flexible payment
plans so a great night's sleep is never
far away for a limited time helix is
offering up to 350 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners this is their best offer yet
so hurry over to helix sleep.com
walsh well uh so
i wanted to mention this this is a uh
big news i guess not really but it's
worth mentioning anyway just crossed a
million followers on twitter
so um i have a million followers on
twitter across a million on youtube as
as you know as we celebrated with my
beautiful uh poetic
inspiring interpretive dance we also
crossed a million
on facebook
and uh facebook does still you know it
is still relevant when i when i
mentioned this on twitter everyone was
like well who's on facebook anymore um i
don't know about three billion people
are on facebook like half of the world's
on facebook actually um
but anyway so that's uh the million
threshold crossed in all those areas in
about the last say month or so
supremely grateful to all the the fans
and friends who've made that possible
and especially to the libs whose
perpetual outrage in my direction has
amplified my voice
and increased my platform like 100 fold
over the last couple of years
and so i want to say to the libs
especially
that i literally could not have done it
without you and i really i do deeply
appreciate it so thank you so much
for your continued support
and patronage
now i want to start with this um
congressional democrats held a rally
yesterday calling to expand the court
the supreme court
and they talked about this of course in
the run-up to the 2020
election and
but it really was it was always
understood that if things don't go their
way
um if it turns out that trump's
nominees
actually are constitutionalists which it
turn which it seems that that all three
of them are to one degree or another
um if that were to happen then that
means we got to expand the court because
as we know again
an institution is broken
the moment it stops doing the bidding of
the left
and even if it's temporary like it
doesn't it doesn't mean that there
doesn't have to be a string of episodes
it's just even one time if an
institution if there's even one
incident where an institution
does something other than what the left
wants that means the institution's
totally broken we've got to completely
tear it down reconfigure it change
everything and so now they want to
expand the court now
there are
some on the left including biden still
who are against this and the reason
they're against it is that they're
afraid that this was this is kind of
opening pandora's box this is uh this is
the nuclear pushing the nuclear button
whatever metaphor you want to use
because
if you do that you know as democrats if
you expand the court to get more of your
own people on there well then the next
time that republicans control the
government then they're going to do the
same thing and then we just have this
sort of arms race where you know 20
years from now the supreme court will
consist of 75
justices right
i actually think i hesitate to say this
out loud
because i don't want the democrats to
expand the court
and uh but but their their worries in
that regard are probably unfounded
because what we know about the
republicans is that they're not gonna up
the ante
like democrats can do something can you
wield a certain power
and uh they might worry that oh are the
republicans going to do it now because
we did it no they won't
they won't so this is the thing the
democrats could add three more justices
supreme court if they wanted to
and when republicans have control
you know there will be people in the
grassroots saying hey guys like they
already did it now we gotta why why
don't you do it well no cause you know
if we do it
then we're hypocrites because we
criticized them when they did it and and
plus if we do it then they're going to
do it more
and we wouldn't want that
so actually democrats can just do
whatever they want and there will be no
repercussions whatsoever
no one tell them that but that's the
reality so here they are this is
congressional democrats holding this
event calling for expanding the court a
few interesting moments like this from
representative bonnie coleman
who seems like someone who wanted to be
in the squad but is too old ageism on
the squad
and but she had this to share something
that i think would make the squad proud
listen to this
a month ago five reactionaries
reactionaries in robes decided that we
don't have constitutional right to an
abortion
in so doing they showed us that they're
willing to eliminate our freedom
to make a decision about our own bodies
and the dodds the jackson women's health
decision imposes the will
of five unelected religious extremists
upon nearly 330
million people i want to share a little
story with you because when we think of
this whole issue of abortion we have
tendency to think of
the young child that gets raped praise
god that he will protect her and help
her to overcome her trauma
a young woman going through her
reproductive years but i had a
conversation with someone i worked with
very closely for the last seven years
who told me at the age of 62
she was still having a period and was
still sexually active with grandchildren
and she said
what
if i got pregnant there's no way at 62 i
would have been in a position to really
be a healthy mommy
to a new baby and so not only is this
impacting the decisions of young women
and the protection of young girls and
others who've been assaulted and raped
but it also impacts the decision of
fully adult women
who have this story to tell
okay so she claims that she knows a 62
year old woman who
could still conceive a child which it's
it's not impossible maybe that's true
uh i'm not sure the oldest woman to ever
give birth to child i don't know what
that is but it's probably over 62. i
will say the average age of menopause is
51. so this would be someone who's over
a decade above the average age and this
could still potentially conceive a child
there's no reason to believe that the
story is true coming from from this
person
anyone on the pro-abortion side they
just lie about everything they lie with
abandon they have no if they have they
have no loyalty fidelity to the truth
whatsoever as we know of course
not only that but they they're actively
hostile to the truth so
no reason to believe it but
let's just pretend for a second that
this person does exist the 62 year old
grandmother that's worried about um
that is worried about conceiving a child
because she's still out you know having
sex with random men
well here's an option
um as a 62 year old woman maybe control
yourself
like
maybe if you're not in a position
where you want to conceive and raise a
child
which i could understand at the age of
62 that would that would
you know that that is not what anyone is
it's usually not in the cards for
anyone's not what they're expecting to
do
um so
maybe control yourself how about that
why have we written out written off that
option completely
why is that not enter into the
conversation at all just control
yourself
um if you are
not in a position
where where
you feel like you're able to
you should conceive a child
if conceiving a child would be
disastrous for you you believe
then
do not participate in activities
that literally billions of times in the
past
have resulted
in the the conception of a child
if reproduction i'm maybe i'll phrase it
this way because i really want to make
it very simple for these people
uh they have difficulty understanding
complex con concepts so got to dumb it
down as much as possible
if reproduction
would be a disaster for you you believe
then do not participate in the
reproductive act
that's all
if you're able to reproduce and yet
reproduction would be a catastrophe
then do not participate in the
reproductive act
um because if you are able to produce
to reproduce
no matter what else you do
you can make it
this quote-unquote safest kind of sex
you want there's always still gonna be a
chance
that you reproduce
and if that chance would be like
plunging off of a cliff level of
catastrophe in your life then don't
participate in the act
control yourself
right we're human beings we should be
able to exercise some self-control
right we're not we're not uh we're not
obese in the jungle that are unable to
control
our
our compulsions at least we shouldn't be
one of the defining features of human
beings one of the things that's supposed
to set us apart from beasts is that we
are able to
have a compulsion to do something we
want to do something and yet we choose
not to do it because we can look forward
into the future in in a way that as far
as we know no other
living creature can on earth we can look
forward into the future and um
understand things on a kind of
theoretical basis we can we can think
five steps ahead like if we do this it
might lead to that which will lead to
that
that's the high level thinking that we
as human beings are capable of so maybe
use that capacity
yourself
especially if you're 62 years old
just an idea
meanwhile activist lauren mounis said
that uh we have to expand the court
not only to save 62 year old
grandmothers from getting
from from getting pregnant but also
in order to save the planet as a whole
let's listen to that
six corporate-backed justices sided with
coal companies over our communities to
make it significantly harder for the epa
to do its job of limiting toxic
emissions and stopping the climate
crisis
i'm here because i know that we need and
deserve a strong democratic government
that protects the safety and needs of
its people not of corporate executives
and that my vision for this government
is not unrealistic nor impossible in
fact it's simply necessary for our
survival
my generation will not sit back and
watch our democratic leadership share
platitudes and dodge responsibility
while the white supremacist gop destroys
our democracy
democrats are at a crossroads they can
continue their current path of
protecting the status quo and we can
keep watching the gop strip away our
fundamental rights
or
they can step up and fight expand the
court and do everything in their power
to protect us and i know my generation
is not going to stop fighting until we
live to see that day
you got to love the people these people
again their narcissism on display she
says my vision for this government who
gives a damn about your vision a lot who
are you lauren mounis my vision for this
government this is my vision i don't
care what your vision is
because what difference does that make
why should that matter at all who are
you
especially when your vision is to
protect democracy quote unquote by
expanding the supreme court to get your
way that's democracy
so no you don't actually have you have
that's the thing with it they have no
problem at all with of course they have
no problem at all with the supreme court
or any court um imposing itself imposing
its will on the american public they
have no this this is what they do this
is this is one of the
primary tools that the left has had
in um
controlling and manipulating the culture
is through the courts
so now because of roe v wade they're
acting like they have some principle
objection
to what they claim is the court imposing
itself now actually what happened with
roe v wade is the opposite of the court
imposing itself it's the court saying
we're getting out of this business
completely
it's the court actually withdrawing
itself from this issue
not in injecting itself the court was
injected into the issue when roe v wade
was decided 50 years ago and the
overturning of roe v wade is the court
getting out of it
the left living in upside down world the
perpetual opposite day is is is claiming
that by getting out of it they're
actually imposing themselves on it and
this is a threat to democracy somehow
it's a threat to democracy to allow the
states to decide the issue to allow
voters and state legislatures to to make
their own decisions as a threat to
democracy and their way to preserve
democracy then is to expand this
institution so that it can impose there
that being the left's will on the
american people right okay that's how
you expand it
that's how you preserve democracy she
says and then of course rashida talib
had a few words to share as well
the other side would not hesitate once
to do what we're about to do which is
continue to push and advocate and i'll
tell you when i've learned over and over
again it's supporting movement
organizations those on the ground that
know what is at stake
and making sure that we are an extension
of what they're doing in the ground and
educating the public because that's how
we got the civil rights act that's how
we got the right to be able to vote
that's how we got the right to be able
to organize labor is when people in the
community demand it so we're going to
stand here with the folks that have
members others that believe in what
we're trying to do which is expand the
court again is incredibly important
we must continue to protect our
democracy that is reflective of the
majority of the american people and
right now six unhinged unelected supreme
court justice
is literally telling women
they have no control over their bodies
no that's the opposite so i refer you
back to what i said a few minutes ago um
no it's it's not that women have no
control over their bodies it's no i see
we as pro-lifers are saying that they do
that you do have control
and you do have self-control
it's just that when it comes to abortion
you're not exercising control over your
own body but you're exercising control
over someone else's body that being your
child and you're destroying that
person's body
so it's got nothing to do with your body
when it comes to just your body uh who
you have sex with when you have sex when
you participate in the reproductive act
when you choose not to you know all
these things that that is totally the
prerogative
of the individual
you do have control over your body and
you should exercise it
it's the left that says actually women
have no control
we can't expect anyone to exercise women
man we can't we can't expect anyone to
exercise any self-control whatsoever
and that's why we have to have this
fail-safe option of uh of killing your
children
because everyone's just gonna run around
having sex with strangers and no one can
stop themselves and they're gonna
produce a whole bunch of babies and uh
the only way to maintain this lifestyle
is to
get rid of those consequences through
violent means if necessary
one other thing on this issue camilla
harris had a little bit more to say on
the abortion issue drawing a parallel
between as we've heard many times
between slavery and uh and abortion
listen
the united states supreme court the
highest court of our land
the
former court of thurgood marshall
took a
constitutional right
that had been recognized
from the people of america from the
women of america
we know
naacp
that our country has a
history of claiming ownership over human
bodies and today
extremist so-called leaders are
criminalizing doctors and punishing
women from making health care decisions
for themselves
okay our country has a history of
claiming ownership over over
human bodies
and that's true
but once again with abortion it is
that is what's happening that that you
know the legalization of abortion
is analogous to slavery in that we are
de-personing an entire group of people
and saying that the mother has total
ownership actual ownership
over the child to the extent of being
able to decide if the child lives or
dies
now we've been over this before but
since this keeps coming up this parallel
between
pro-lifers and slave owners
i just want to review this again um
just as a handy reference
because i've often said that actually
every argument for abortion directly
parallels an argument
that slave owners use to justify slavery
and i've made this claim and i've gone
through the arguments before we're gonna
go over them again
just to review okay so
and i really mean every single one like
every argument that slave owners use to
justify abortion can find a parallel in
the arguments that pro-abortion people
use to justify abortion i will show you
the argument from ownership
this slave slash baby is my property
slash body you can't tell me what to do
with it
there's the argument from privacy no one
is forcing you to have slaves slash
abortions mind your own business
there's the argument from the
superseding rights my property slash
body rights come before the rights of a
slave fetus there's the argument from
inevitability slavery abortion has been
around for thousands of years it's never
going away we might as well have a safe
and legal system in place for it there's
the argument from pseudoscience slave
slash fetuses aren't really people they
aren't like us look at them they're
physically different therefore we are
people and they are not there's the
argument from socioeconomics if slavery
slash abortion ends most of these slave
slash babies will end up on the street
without a job
there's the argument from the court
slavery abortion was vindicated by the
supreme court it's already been decided
there's no point in arguing it although
that argument is now out the window for
abortion just as eventually it was with
slavery
there's the argument from faux
compassion
slavery slash abortion is in the best
interest of african slash babies the
world can be a cruel place it's best to
protect them from it by keeping them
enslaved killing them then there's the
argument from the assumed hypocrisy of
the other side you say you want to end
slavery slash abortion but you don't
want to live with freed black slash
adopt unwanted babies for yourself
that's pretty much every argument that
was that was
uh put forward to justify slavery and as
we see same exact arguments being made
because as it turns out when you have
movements
um that are based around the unpersoning
the de-personing of other groups of
people they always sound the same it's
just history repeating itself or as the
saying goes if history doesn't repeat it
at least rhymes and that's what we see
here
all right uh what else do we got here
this is i thought this was kind of funny
from the la times so here's a little bit
of the article as it first appeared
it says california has been a pioneer in
pushing for rooftop solar power
building up the largest solar market in
the u.s more than 20 years and 1.3
million rooftop rooftop rooftops later
the bill is coming due beginning in 2006
the state focused on how to incentivize
people to take up solar power
showered subsidies on homeowners who
installed
photovoltaic panels but had no
comprehensive plan to dispose of them
now panels purchased under those
programs are nearing the end of their
typical 25 to 30-year life cycle many
are already winding up in landfills
where in some cases they could
potentially contaminate groundwater with
toxic heavy metals such as lead selenium
and cadmium
sam vanderhoof a solar industry expert
and chief executive of recycle pv solar
says that only 1 in 10 panels are
actually recycled according to estimates
drawn from the international renewable
energy agency data on decommissioned
panels and from industry leaders the
looming challenge over how to handle
truckloads of waste
some of it contaminated illustrates how
cutting-edge environmental policy can
create unforeseen problems down the road
so it's very very interesting we were
told that solar panels solar energy is
the way forward it's our way towards um
you know saving the planet it's a it's a
it's a source of energy with no real
downside
as opposed to all the fossil fuels that
are destroying the planet and now we
find out that well there is a downside
actually because now you've got all
these solar panels with the toxic uh
subs made of toxic substances they end
up in land fills and then eventually
that leaks into the ground water and it
contaminates and everything else
well the left didn't like the fact that
this article was published especially by
the the la times it felt like a betrayal
to them and so
um that led to the editors at the la
times making a whole bunch of
adjustments after publication and that
led to i think one of the most lengthy
editors notes
i've ever seen
this is the editor's note now after this
our article got so much backlife says an
earlier version of this article
mischaracterized the environmental risk
posed by heavy metals in consumer uh
photovoltaic arrays this story has been
edited to clarify that panels containing
toxic materials are routed for disposal
to landfills with extra safeguards
against leakage and to note that panels
that contain cadmium and selenium are
primarily used in utility-grade
applications an earlier version of this
article also misattributed a statement
by evelyn butler vice president of
technical services at the solar energy
industries association to jen bristol
the group's senior director of
communications it also misidentified the
group as the solar energy industry
association an earlier version of this
article also failed to properly
attribute quotes by jigar shah director
of the department of energy's loan
programs office to their source a 2020
interview with pv magazine
the article has also been updated to
reflect shah's current professional
affiliation as well as that of sam
vanderhoff an earlier version of this
article also stated that 25 years was
the life cycle of photovoltaic panels
the text has been updated to reflect
that 25 to 30 years as a typical service
but life but not a fixed limit
additionally in a discussion of the
transporting voltaic panels to recycling
or hazardous waste disposal facilities
the word cells has been changed to
panels for accuracy so
uh just the entire thing basically was
was rewritten
with this with this editor's note on top
of it
what you get from this is that there's
there is a lot of sloppy reporting of
course in the mainstream media with the
l.a times they got a lot of names wrong
and they misattributed things it's just
incredibly sloppy reporting but at the
same time they were also trying to blunt
the edges a little bit by saying well
it's not 25 years it's 25 to 30. you
know that kind of thing um adding that
in there to quell some of the outrage uh
but that doesn't change the fact that
there is still this downside to solar
panels and we haven't there are other
downsides too i mean just the fact like
how much room they take up
um you end up with you know if you
really want to to
power large areas with solar panels that
means you have to
install a whole whole field acres and
acres and acres of solar panels and how
do you you know where do you find the
room for that you're cutting down trees
and everything else
what what that means is that
every green energy alternative that's
supposed to save the planet has its own
pitfalls some more than others
okay but there's no discussion of the
trade-offs ever
there's no acknowledgement
that no matter what we do
because we live on this planet
we are going to leave behind waste okay
we're gonna we're gonna leave a mark no
matter what we do
that doesn't mean that uh we should make
no attempt to contain the waste it
doesn't mean that it's not necessarily a
problem we should try to fix but
there you know the environmentalists are
always looking for the utopian solution
how can we
be a human human an advanced human
civilization
and um power ourselves and and maintain
all the luxuries of living in modern
society the luxuries that of course none
of them want to give up or have given up
and yet leave no mark on the planet
whatsoever and that's just not possible
as it turns out
one other final thing before we get to
the comment section this is uh i look
kind of funny pink
the singer if you remember her she
hasn't made a good song in well forever
she's never made a good song but she
hasn't made a hit song in probably about
20 years in recent years she's taken to
just ranting about conservatives on
social media
a few weeks ago she's i think she was
the one who said that she doesn't want
pro-lifers to listen to her music at all
that's how much she hates us a request
which i am more than happy to abide by
in fact i i respect her request so much
that i have been respecting it before 20
years before she even made it that's how
much i respect her as a person
anyway she has a new song out called
irrelevant
in which she partly complains about
being called irrelevant which is
hilarious already but in the song and in
the music video in her bid for relevance
she just throws every
woke virtue singling thing she can into
the mix and she just throws them all
into a blender and mixes them together
and you you hear that in the song but
especially in the video which we'll play
a little bit of right now watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
i think it might rain today
ash on the ground
took all the heat we could take
and then burn it down
now it's a real parade
we're all welcome now
as long as you feel afraid
that's what it's about
you can call me irrelevant insignificant
you can try to make me small
i'll be your heretic you hypocrite
i won't think of you at all
[Music]
okay so you get the idea uh we start
with obama you know aoc pro-abortion
protesters they're the good guys then we
get to the bad guys and she lumps in
pro-lifers conservative supreme court
justices and goes right to images of
nazis and the clan later on she shows
the january 6th riots uh like i said the
whole kitten caboodle there but but
here's the point that i have to make
again because it's it's um
it's really interesting to see this kind
of happen
art on the left
music films tv all of that
it's all now headed in the same
direction as christian music and
christian films
um in fact this song even sounds kind of
like a christian like a christian rock
song just the words are very different
and the imagery is very different the
message is different but the sound
is like something you would hear on one
of these christian music stations
the circle is going all the way around
and now mainstream art
makes the same mistake that christian
music and film has made for many years
and that is putting the message above
the art itself going message first art
second
and then you you end up with this kind
of lame repetitive uninteresting content
and it hits the messaging notes that you
want but it's not very good art
and i think one of the reasons why
that's happening on the left
is that
great art requires some friction right
it requires some resistance some
frustration
in order to be created i think most
great art is born partly from
frustrations think about all the
all of the revolutions in the music
industry um when new sounds and artists
and musical genius burst onto the scene
they always had
some sort of
uh they always had to push their way in
against forces that wanted to keep them
out there's the stereotype of the
tortured artist right and there's a lot
of truth to that stereotype it might not
hold in every case but it holds in many
of them
the problem is that if you're on the
left
especially if you're relatively wealthy
and well off
then you experience no friction um you
you are not standing against the
cultural current at all but you're
floating on it easily and softly that's
one of the reasons why you see
especially these aging pop stars who
maybe arguably were a little bit
counter-cultural in the 70s 80s and some
of the 90s not very much but a little
bit
and then they had some success they made
a lot of money and and now they're
living in a culture living partly in the
culture they created
um and they're very comfortable and
they're not counter culture anymore at
all anymore they're now the vanguards of
the culture the culture they created and
so there's just there's no friction
there there's no frustration to to
create great art they have nothing left
to say
as evidence partly by this pink song
although in fairness she never really
had anything to say i guess let's get
now to the comment section
[Music]
sarah michelle says on behalf of the
fans i would like to ask the daily wire
to let matt stay on vacation
indefinitely this whole vibe just suits
him the rustic cabin the mood lighting
uh and then a
how this i love this comment and then
you you threw in the emoji at the end i
don't know what that emoji is supposed
to mean is that a kissing emoji that you
put at the end of this
i was i was with you i was like i was
about to
promote you to a new station in the spg
but now because of that kissing emoji
you're you're banished from the show
you're banned from the show but i do
appreciate that comment and i and i look
i
if that's what the people want
if the people want me to just stay on
vacation forever then then i i for one
am willing to heed the call of the
people i'm a man of the people
i don't know if the daily wire will
agree but
if that's what you want as far as i am
concerned your wish is my command um jim
says
quoting me it's rare for an armed
bystander to stop an active shooter oh
wait that's not quoting me it's quoting
a cnn article it's rare for an armed
bystander to stop an active shooter and
jim says sounds like we need more armed
bystanders then well that's that is
certainly one way of looking at it and i
agree with you
um
let's see
aids says matt since you banished me
from the show my life has fallen into
shambles my wife left me my kids won't
speak to me i'm homeless now and even
the absence of nourishment is not even
close to the pain i feel for not being a
part of the sweet baby gang today i ask
you and the sweet baby gang to once
again
embrace me as a fellow member of the
gang that makes the twitter mob fly off
the handle with rage i await your ever
loving forgiveness
well if you were ever a true and
dedicated member of the spg you would
know that the cult leader has no
capacity for loving forgiveness which
only shows that your banishment was was
just and will continue i'm afraid to say
uh jim says
uh the earliest mention i've seen of
the cultural
of the uh rather climate apocalype
predictions is back from 1990 when the
bbc put out a documentary called after
the warming according to their climate
models by the year 2020 global
temperatures were to have risen by 15 to
25 degrees there's actually a cheerful
thought comparing our actual performance
to their predictions we can safely say
the strategy we've adopted mostly
nothing is the correct one to avoid
catastrophic warming
right that's that that is that's true
that's one of the consequences of these
continual
and i guess it goes back all the way to
1990 i guess that's true because i can
remember
one thing is that the climate
apocalypse the vision of the apocalypse
has also changed over time
and um it's only in the last couple of
decades when it became well it became
global warming and they changed it to
climate change before that there was
predictions of an ice age there was a
nuclear winter there's all kinds of
overpopulation and some of these things
they still keep in the mix
overpopulation they keep in the mix
global warming obviously is still there
they've changed it to climate change
because that encompasses everything i
guess they got tired the
environmentalists chicken littles got
tired of changing the apocalypse every
20 years so then they just said you know
what it's climate change that's what
we're worried about any kind of change
at all doesn't matter
um
i can remember when i was a kid
yeah i did hear about global warming a
little bit
but especially elementary middle school
that wasn't the big one the big one was
the hole in the ozone layer
and uh in particular deforestation and
again they still keep that they still
talk about that but
uh i was convinced as a young child that
because this is what we were told
in our elementary school brainwashing
sessions
which aren't nearly as bad as the
brainwashing sessions they do these days
but still they were pretty bad
i was convinced that uh that we were all
gonna suffocate
soon because they were chopping down the
trees and we wouldn't be able to breathe
i mean that's what we were told by
teachers
um
so this goes back many many years but
the thing is
all these predictions and then
especially when they put a date on it
then you get to the date and everyone's
still alive and everything seems to be
okay
that only proves that as you as you say
our strategy of mitigation is working
and namely
our strategy is to do nothing apparently
that works we could just do that's the
good news we can do nothing at all
and live our lives and still manage to
evade all of these disasters
that's great that's that's something to
be happy about
after witnessing the james webb
telescope so beautifully capture the
great unknown reminding us of our
unfathomably minuscule place in the
cosmos you have to wonder
if my truth that aliens are real is the
truth
that being said we need to do more um i
think the alien shirt we launched last
week was a step in the right direction
here's the shirt by the way if you
haven't seen it yet i'll put it up for
you i keep it here
even if i you know i don't wear it
because i like to be able to look at it
that's how much peace and comfort it
brings me
but that's not nearly enough this is why
i'm happy to announce that july's
installment of my patch program over at
dailywire.com shop is the aliens are
real patch right to the point cuts right
to the chase no longer will this
marginalized group be subject to the
cruelty of erasure last month's patch is
sold out so be sure to head over to my
swag shack today to validate the alien
community and give the support it
deserves my truth is out there
somewhere lost in those stunning nebulas
and distant galaxies i know it we all
know it so get that patch also this week
we're celebrating the first anniversary
of our of our podcast warning wire in
this short period of time it's become
one of the top news podcasts i suspect
it's because morningwire gives you the
only only the news you need to know in
15 minutes or less cutting right to the
chase without the manufactured outrage
without the political bias about any of
that new episodes are available every
morning seven days a week and they cover
stories other media outlets won't touch
so check out morning wire on apple
podcasts spotify daily wire plus or
wherever you listen to podcasts and
while you're at it check out the rest of
our extensive content library at
dailywireplus.com
like the docu-series fauci unmasked
hosted by michael knowles in light of
fouchy's retirement announcement this is
a great way to celebrate and right now
you get 35 off of your new daily wire
plus membership so head to
dailywireplus.com today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
the cry went up across the land mourning
and wailing in the street a great
tragedy had occurred a travesty and
injustice of cosmic proportions proof
again
that racism is alive and well in this
country and um now we have as a nation
tumbled all the way back to
pre-abolition days the clock has been
turned back that's how unspeakable this
event was how terrible the outrage how
horrific how dreadful how ghastly
as headlines in every major media that
have reported a sesame street character
committed a hate crime
against two black children
well not the character herself but uh
but a person in the sesame street
costume and it wasn't a hate crime
exactly but it's close enough according
to the racial outrage page brigade
anyway nbc news has the chilling story
it says a mother of two young black
girls is calling out sesame place
philadelphia after she says her
daughters were intentionally dismissed
by a performer dressed as a sesame
street character over the weekend
sparking a fierce backlash online in the
now viral video posted saturday on the
mother's instagram account two young
girls are seen excitedly reaching out to
the character rosita the first bilingual
muppet on sesame street although it
appears the performer had interacted
with other children before reaching the
girls the video seems to show the
character shaking their head no in the
direction of the two young black girls
the actual video is about five seconds
long
and uh quite grim so prepare yourself
for this
here it is
shocking
we have no context here at all we have
only five seconds of a costume mascot
walking in a parade but uh it is
certainly enough to leap to very
specific conclusions about the person in
the costume and about sesame place and
about sesame street and that's how the
mother of these girls felt anyway she uh
she posted the video and explained that
um
after her children were deprived of a
high five
from this character
she demanded to speak to a supervisor
but she was rebuffed because for one
thing we can assume that the other
people in the parade had no idea who the
supervisor of the parade was or if that
position existed like it's not what
you're expecting in a parade for someone
to say hey let me speak to your
supervisor
of what the parade you want the
you know the karen slur is meant to
degrade white women specifically but
if the label means anything at all
it must surely apply to a woman who
asked to speak to the manager of the
parade because her kids didn't get
enough high fives
anyway even if she could not rectify the
situation
through speaking to a manager her
instagram post was enough to get her the
15 minutes of fame and more importantly
15 additional victim points
that she desired the incident went viral
and the race-baiters went to work leslie
mack who is a digital strategist with
pronouns in her bio
was one of the accounts that helped to
take this outrage du jour to the next
level she tweeted
quote
baby paige and her cute little friends
went to sesame place this weekend to
celebrate paige's fourth birthday and
this is how sesame place treated these
beautiful black children i'm hot
another account got 42 000 retweets with
this melodramatic take on the situation
quote
it's upsetting because no matter what
damage control is attempted by sesame
place nothing can undo how these babies
were made to feel in this moment
the looks on their faces are
so heartbreaking
you know some people have their hearts
broken by images of children
starving to death in third world
countries um some are heartbroken by
death disease violence and misery of
other sorts
and others are heartbroken because two
children were mildly disappointed when a
parade mascot didn't wave to them
i guess heartbreak is in the eye of the
beholder
you know soon people of course were
sharing other examples of black children
not being given sufficient attention
from costumed characters in various
situations others were calling for the
person in the mascot suit to be
identified and publicly shamed prominent
race-baiters like tariq nasheed got in
on the action the sheet alleging that
the costume character has quote a
deliberate pattern of snubbing children
of color then a attorney benjamin clump
tweeted his own sentiments of heartbreak
before presumably parachuting onto the
scene to get in front of cameras and
file lawsuits
actually i'm kidding the family did not
hire ben crump
shockingly but they did hire a different
race-baiting lawyer who is going to be
he says
investigating the situation
other famous figures weighed in
beyonce's former intern kelly rowland
posted the clip to instagram and
declared that she was so mad and then
actor wendell pierce of the wire fame
went for and probably i think won the
faux outrage gold medal
with his analysis of the situation
tweeting this this is this is not meant
to be a joke this is what he actually
tweeted and this is to remind you
about children not being given a high
five by a mascot in a prey this is what
he said
witness the end of innocence witness the
trauma this moment is violent scarring
psychological abuse
watching it reminds me of my own four
years old and mardi gras day being
denied the joy i see other kids having
and the realization the horrible reality
the immediate loss
pain you know in fairness he sounds like
me when i go to order a beer at a
restaurant and they tell me they don't
have any ipas on tap
you know i also shout this is something
similar witness the end of innocence
witness the trauma
and then i'm shot with the tranquilizer
darden carried away by men in white
coats a service that somebody should
probably provide to uh wendell there
because he really seems to need it
so
how will sesame place respond to all of
this performative maniacally stupid and
asinine nonsense will they ignore it
will they laugh in the faces of their
ridiculous disingenuous critics will
they issue a statement saying hi boys
and girls today's letter of the day is s
s is for shut the hell up you damned
crybabies
will they do any of that
only in my utopian fantasies in real
life they issued not one
but two apologies the first came in the
form of a of an explanation it read in
part
quote our brand our park and our
employees stand for inclusivity and
equality in all forms regarding the
incident yesterday the costumes our
performers wear sometimes make it
difficult to see at lower levels and
sometimes our performers miss hug
requests from guests the performer
portraying the rosita character has
confirmed that the no hand gesture seen
several times in the video was not
directed to any specific person rather
was a response to multiple requests from
someone in the crowd
who asked rosita to hold their child for
a photo which is not permitted
that's the explanation perfectly logical
but when that perfectly logical
explanation was not accepted they tried
again with a more groveling tone this is
what they this is what they is the
statement they issued a few hours later
we sincerely apologize to the family for
their experience in our park on saturday
we know that it's not okay we're taking
actions to do better we are committed to
making this right we will conduct
training for our employees so they
better understand recognize and deliver
an inclusive equitable and entertaining
experience for our guests for over 40
years sesame place has worked uphold the
values of respect inclusion and
belonging we are committed to doing a
better job making children and families
feel special seen and included when they
come to our parks
you know they just said that the mascot
didn't do anything wrong
and the whole thing's being taken out of
context based on a five-second
conveniently cropped and edited video
and now they say that what the person in
the costume did though totally innocent
and being wildly and intentionally
misconstrued
was not okay and that they will do
better
which of course means subjecting their
employees to more racial sensitivity
brainwashing we can assume and making
sure that every costumed character knows
that they must make a special point of
identifying and singling out every
non-white child in the crowd or it will
cost them their jobs
the white children don't matter of
course i mean they can be snubbed all
day long and nobody will care
which of course
white children are snubbed by mascots
all the time
i have four white children and i have
witnessed it with my own eyes
unlike this mother though i'm always
relieved when the costumed freaks don't
come over to us as i find them all both
annoying and slightly disturbing
so i don't mind when they don't go and
the other thing is if the mascot walks
by and one of my kids starts whining
about it he didn't say hi to me i don't
i don't cry oh you poor baby you're
heartbroken i say hey stop whining
we're at this parade you think i want to
be here
show some gratitude
that's my response okay it's a slightly
different parenting strategy
and the thing is you know we know that
in these costumes your field of
vision inside one of those sweaty furry
cocoons is about as limited as an
armored medieval knight in a jousting
competition with you know one small slit
to peer through it's almost certain that
the person in the costume could not see
the children in fact
walking in a parade past hundreds of
children he will not see or interact
with most of them
this explanation certainly makes a lot
more sense than the fantastical
assumption that the person in the
costume is a raging anti-black racist
who though working in philadelphia and
interacting with hundreds of black
customers every day
randomly decided to take his or her
racist energies out on two black girls
that explanation makes zero sense
while the other one makes 100 sense
of course of the two choices the
race-baiting leftists take the zero
sense option
because they're bored and they lead
miserably empty lives and they find
momentarily they find momentary meaning
in these performances of outrage
also because they're desperate to be
victims you know a desperation that also
stems from their bored and empty lives
but they live in decadence and luxury
and therefore are deprived of true
opportunities to experience the
oppression they think they want
so they settle for getting madder to
muppet
meanwhile black children are actually
traumatized and abused and scarred and
worse every single day in this country
wendell pierce's words would apply to
the situation faced by a great many
black children in this country
i'm talking about the black children
growing up in gang-ridden
violence-plagued communities with no
fathers in the home being raised by a
drug-addicted mother and her rotating
cast of boyfriends
i'm talking about black children whose
innocence have been so thoroughly
destroyed that they are as a recent
viral video showed out in the street
before the age of five cussing out and
assaulting police officers
now those are black children who could
use some of this surplus of outrage and
sympathy and concern
but they're ignored
because their situation is not helpful
to the narrative
it's not as easy to racialize it
certainly is not as easy to blame whitey
the real victims are silenced and
ignored and new martyrs are made
this time martyrs at the hands of a
muppet
and that's why the sesame street outrage
brigade is today
certainly canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomblin our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matt well show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20
today on the ben shapiro show as record
temperatures hit the uk talk of
environmental crackdowns heat up prince
harry tells the un the right is
destroying democracy in america plus joe
biden's undersecretary of hhs says it's
time to empower young people to change
their gender that's today on the bench
bureau show give it a listen